foreign
hello and welcome this is active
inference guest stream number 35.1 it's
January 24th 2023.
today we're here with Jordan Hall and
Matthew burkowski we're going to have a
very interesting discussion so thank you
both for joining we will begin with a
Hello introduction from Jordan Matthew
will then set some context that will
launch us into a dialogue that will take
us on through so thanks again and Jordan
please
um since I lied in the Preamble so a
little bit of introduction I'm noticing
and this is I think part of the real
interest of having a conversation with
Matthew
um
uh is something like it would be nice I
think and plausible for us to actually
produce something new and useful in this
90-minute time span and I expect that
we'll want to be using something like a
a transparadigmatic method so we should
be grabbing Concepts from a variety of
different uh disciplines and frames and
applying them in the area of inquiry and
endeavoring to use that to actually
identify something that is specific and
perhaps hasn't been as articulated or
deeply investigated at least to my
awareness of course
um before and so the end result
hopefully will actually be worth worth
actually having been done and to have
been participated in
that's probably I I mean I I hope that
at least this recording in and of itself
as an artifact will be something useful
for a number of people who uh who might
have been paying attention to the
initial context and that we can bring
together as we typically do uh the many
types of frames that we've been
exploring uh in between our
conversations that are that are quite uh
quite fertile and oftentimes barefooter
in conversation so I'm always I always
look forward to our conversation
specifically for that reason
um
why we are here this morning or I guess
what did catalyze this initially was a
tweet that kind of randomly sent out the
other day as I had a network of Concepts
floating around in my head around uh
emergence governance the Tendencies uh
toward which that pattern flows and
so the Tweet may be the best to just
read it
um so
because that all forms of governance
Trend toward parasitic corruption should
be the first quote-unquote law of
political quote-unquote science the only
questions are how long before this
becomes unsustainable does it also
generate valuable byproducts and will it
will it fail catastrophically or
adaptively and so you know just the
general frame for the conversation is
something along the lines of
as we move through the world together
and attempt to identify points of
tension uh in terms of the relationship
between our communities and the
embedding context in which they exist
and attempt to navigate the world such
that they can retain their ability to to
function to cohere
um to generate new solutions that help
them mediate the tensions in the world
that are constantly attempting to or
constantly acting as a force against
those structures as we come together to
try to to to
um to network ourselves such that we can
function adaptively right to create
systems for doing so and that's evolved
you know quite a bit over time from uh
informal systems at the tribal level at
smaller social scales uh with respect to
uh structures that had much greater
coherence just as a function of the fact
that everyone knew each other everyone
was around one another uh in a daily
context uh had a deep history in terms
of their relational contextual knowledge
of uh those interpersonal relations
these lineages and so you didn't need a
great deal of abstraction in the
quote-unquote political domain you
didn't need to conceptualize an abstract
structure and then attempt to convince
people that this was the legitimate
structure to buy into as a stewardship
mechanism for themselves but as we
scaled up you know we started to
introduce these sorts of abstractions
um and and we are certainly in a time
now where you know it's worth asking
this question is as we create
abstractions that are uh into which we
pour our political energies you know for
example the idea of democratic
governance or you know the the sort of
Republic that uh we live in in the
United States
um
to what extent is their tendency uh of
those who are given stewardship over
that given their placement given their
necessity necessary placement within
this mechanism but also uh animate stuff
they have a mechanism but also just the
structure of that mechanism uh being
responsible as a small subset of the
population for stewarding its large
abstraction uh and this large degree of
attention and this large degree of
responsibility uh is it possible for
that to be resistant to corruption
across long periods of time is it
inevitable that uh that corruption will
exist and this was the claim in the
Tweet uh that people will fundamentally
begin to make choices that uh that that
direct all of that attention energy
toward their own ends as opposed to the
ends ostensible ends of the collective
um and then if that is a given
um
what frames can we hold despite the fact
that this is a given that can still act
as evaluative criteria and so a useful
evaluated criteria which is what sort of
those three ideas
um that I provided related to in terms
of the degree to which that can be an
unsustainable or a sustainable structure
um to the extent that it still generates
valuable byproducts even though that
that corruption is necessary or
inherently emergent within it or
um whether it will fail catastrophically
or adaptively will it essentially uh
will it undermine itself entirely or
will it actually within itself despite
that corruption uh be able to surface
new patterns into which itself can fail
uh as a kind of Lifeboat that
increasingly expands its own capacity so
that was you know I'll kind of step away
now and just give time for a reflection
and
um analysis on y'all's part
um but that was just sort of the initial
frame that I think catalyzed some
conversation here
all right well there's a there's a whole
bunch of different things that um are I
think implicated and I noticed that
I want to just kind of put a put a
variety of different uh plates on the
table without having to
um
understand exactly what meal we're
eating just yet so
in no particular order one thing that
comes up is
I feel like there's a there's an
invocation of a frame that I've used a
lot and that is something along the
lines of like major eras or apocs in the
Arc of evolution specifically in the
context of humans and so the first era
um wide which I which I refer to often
as unconscious Evolution or ordinary
Evolution what is the is the period I
think you were referring to be something
like lineage where there's the The
Binding constraints the various kinds of
characteristics of uh behavior that
steer the collective Choice making of a
group of
um
sort of indigenous humans uh was largely
a consequence of a very long
time and iterations under the ordinary
constraints of what I'll just call
ordinary biological evolution so lots of
trial and error and conservation of
relatively fit behaviors very tightly
knit and with all the various advantages
that are associated with that
um modality of exploring possibility
space
the second year of the second apoc
would be conscious design and I think
this is the domain where we see most of
the problematics and I'll invoke people
like tainter and [__] as other
individuals who've pointed to the
problematics that seem to be intrinsic
to the apoc or the modality of conscious
design and of course one of the sort of
most fundamental challenges is that it
exits us from the equilibrium or the
homeostatic feedback loops that are
characteristic of unconscious Evolution
so humans are able to operate in the
mode of conscious design we begin to
create novelty in the environment that
produces asymmetry in relationship with
all the other feedback loops that we
happen to have been embedded in
contextually but we don't actually fully
understand the consequences of the
asymmetries that we're producing and
this creates a whole series of cascade
effect so change explores that in the
context of how a designed social
infrastructure produces an arc that has
a built-in closure because as we sort of
play out the entropy that was built into
the Inception of that social
infrastructure which may take
Generations or even many many
generations we find ourselves collapsing
back into the complex domain of the
unconscious evolutionary basis and then
we have a reset I think [__] more or
less explores the same basic Dynamic
within the particular domain of Science
and I think they're they're largely if
you look at them as being examples of a
more generalized problematic you can
then or or even Dynamic you can then use
that to create a meta Theory
um
similarly I'm not sure exactly who
studied this most carefully perhaps
Hayek looking at it in the context of
businesses which have a very similar and
very well studied Dynamic the the
s-curve of a business structure where an
entrepreneurial
um group usually one or two or five
Founders like a very small group
operating in many ways principally from
the unconscious evolutionary stage like
operating in very much a human
indigenous modality using a lot of the
basic human dynamics to be in deep
relationship with each other and form a
very fluid open coherent governance
um highly generative produces a large
gradient or a large well of potential
but then as it structures itself into
the conscious design mode it starts
creating an organizational structure it
plays the various tools and in many ways
kind of replicates The Arc of social
structures in general recreating the
rise and fall of civilizations and then
form some form of closure that
eventually dies since I think it's
studied pretty thoroughly in a number of
different locations
um
and given that languaging and I haven't
actually brought in parasite which is a
very good you know so it's just bringing
parasite and the notion of Niche right
so a general principle of evolution is
that every Niche will be ultimately
explored and there's something about
both the presence of entropy in design
constructs or actually any any kind of
uh gradient or any any kind of gradient
has a dynamic of entropy but it also has
the dynamic of
once the gradient is produced that
gradient represents a niche and the
exploration and exploitation of that
niche of which parasitism is one uh
fundamental strategy seems to be
something that needs to be we need to be
aware of and think about how that's
addressed
across different apocs
um and then the the last piece I would
throw out is something like okay uh if
we're endeavoring to move into a third
mode which would be something like the
apoc of conscious evolutionary approach
which is able to sort of combine the
best of the both and perhaps avoid the
negatives of both by the way entirely by
hypothesis they have no reason to
believe this is I have no compelling
reason to believe this is actually
plausible
um
one of the things that might be
interesting is to look at the phenotype
genotype Dynamic I.E Evolution seems to
have woven at a very deep level
uh what I'll call a modal a very
profound modal shift which is that all
phenotypes die
but there's continuity in the phenotype
produces
uh a embodied version of the genotype so
the genotype has continuity exclusively
however mediated by the phenotype and
the phenotype has a kind of continuity
but exclusively mediated by the genotype
and the two are very very distinct in
terms of their physical characteristics
right the things that are associated
with energetic gradients are
qualitatively distinct and the shifting
back and forth between the two seems to
be a solution to the kind of problem
that we're actually talking about
um okay so that's what I'm putting into
the into the mix into the stew
number of ingredients to work with
um yeah so beginning
at the beginning of your statement with
respect to uh the introduction of [__]
uh hike and
um tainter
so the
just give me some grammatic work I think
we have to do as well here because
there's uh
he used the word closure a couple of
times and uh the manner in which he used
it uh was sort of uh and sort of the
epoch ending book and context uh in a
way is that does that is that a fair
characterization of how you you felt you
were using it in a way is that sort of
yeah it has like the closing of uh the
closing of an era the end of an error
the end of a phase I think even even
more pointedly to the notion of a uh a
thermodynamically closed system
these kinds of systems the proposition
I'm making is that they are closed
systems and so therefore they have a uh
a finite time until they achieve
something like an entropic equilibrium
and that sort of does that that Arc of
the playing out of that time is the
story of their of their of their
particular I would propose
okay interesting yeah and I mean so
there's always there's always there's
this fascinating tension along the lines
of sort of uh stable or unstable
equilibriums or you know if you if you
want to layer in another I'm not sure
how familiar you are the work of Terence
Deacon but he he's quite interesting in
so far as he provides thermodynamic
Frameworks around the ideas of uh
different
um emergent behaviors that flow from
sort of this first homeodynamic level
which is systems that tend to be uh um
that tend to essentially equilibrium so
so he introduced a little bit of
language called the ortho grade as a
sort of abstract general term of like a
number of systems that tend toward a uh
a more homogeneous State let's say or a
more stable State and then Contra grade
which is essentially the capacity of any
system to given an ambient orthograde
context to to sort of act against that
in some way
um continuously or with some degree of
stability and he builds a framework of
um you know actually showing that
certain types of
um structure itself and this kind of
resonates with a lot of Kaufman's work
in terms of uh the the origins of order
looking for
non-evolutionary just uh physical
constraints that give Horizon processes
that interact with those physical
constraints that themselves give rise to
certain forms of order in the world so
uh you know Deacon's claim is something
along the lines of two types of systems
that might themselves tend toward stable
more dissipative structure if put in
relationship in a particular way with
one another can then give rise to at
that sort of frustration boundary afloat
through that frustration boundary give
rise to some sort of actual structure in
the world or pattern in the world and
the architectural example he uses there
is something called like a Rayleigh
Bernard cell which is heat trying to our
energy trying to flow through uh water
or oil at a with a particular viscosity
um and you know the first thing you get
is the actual bubbling of the heat
rising but at a particular point the
energy can't escape efficiently enough
so it actually takes on the test the
structure of you know hexagonal lattice
so you get these little cells right and
um if you've ever been to like the
Pacific Northwest or other areas with
like Basalt uh rock with these hexagonal
columns you can actually see this exact
thing embodied when lava cools and then
cools and tries to cool release that
energy in the same way and performs
these giant hexagon hexagonal Rock
structures
um in any case my whole point of
introducing that line of thought is that
I think that there are with respect to
you know homeodynamic
systems uh this idea of closure is an
interesting one because people are
researchers such as the commodity or
Kaufman as well with his work cycles and
uh montavilla masu they have this idea
of constraint closures which is why I
went in this direction which is deeply
tied into the question of in their idea
of their conception uh they they use the
concept of a of a constraint as sort of
a symmetry across time
um and so that symmetry across time uh
think of something like an enzyme right
the enzyme has its own structure that is
maintained across time but in its
interaction with some other process it
sort of locally breaks that symmetry to
produce a transformation and it sort of
acts as a sort of you could look at it
as like a like a functional or dynamical
um like boundary that also changes what
bounces off of it and then if you order
these boundaries in a particular way you
know and close that Loop which is where
you get this closure which is in many
ways the way that I I tend to use the
word closure these days the reason I'm
laying this groundwork is just because
this idea of closure is very fundamental
the kind of ways I've been thinking
about this particular topic of emergency
governance
um if you know once that becomes closed
uh then you can start talking about
these patterns of Auto catalysis uh
whether that's a self-reinforcing loop
and what it actually self-reinforces uh
and to the extent that we're talking
about governance uh I think it's
relevant because of the fact that at
each one of those points right there are
aspects there are side effects of that
of that function that are the inputs of
one of these other functions but then
there are also side effects that can
have uh other uh functions in the
context in which disclosure might exist
and I think when we're talking about
governance and the the life cycle of
governance we might be talking about
something like that initial closure
coming into being functionally such that
it's overall net byproducts might be
adaptive but to the extent we become
reflexive in understanding this is that
conscious evolution is conscious
management to the extent that we can
identify the closure and start mapping
it and actually and analyzing the points
and the flows within our own minds as
individuals we can start playing games
with it to the extent that that closure
and its side effects shift to a point
where you know it actually shunts
perhaps some of that energy that should
be going to the Adaptive capacity of the
overall closure into sort of sub games
of people's individual political
Dynamics personal lives wealth building
Endeavors that are within their own
frame of reference but not represented
in that closure that they are now able
to see and take advantage of right which
you you might also introduce laterally
and things with the cantion effect where
it's like if you're close to the money
spigot and you see the game that's being
played you are more capable of taking
literally that energy that's being
released into the market and directing
it into places that you know might be
more to your own interests even if you
are saying and claiming that they're in
the general interest of that that
broader Collective closure that we've
created uh supposedly in the economic
sense by the FED to to maintain
homeostatic or homeodynamic stability at
this this financial level so you know
when you kind of bring in those those
Concepts they're very resonant with the
way I've been thinking about it but um I
just wanted to sort of establish that
context for Grammar with respect to
closure because I think it's quite
critical to the way I've also been
thinking about these tendencies
yeah that was great thank you
um so
with regard to that so the that last
Point
um when we're looking at the particular
phenomenon or in human endeavor of
governance we have a special case and I
like I think this is very interesting to
be able to focus so the general case we
could talk about in the context of folks
like uh tainter and uh [__] and Hayek
which is just things that happen in
human-built kinds of organizational
systems that have these various Dynamics
built in governance is particular
because it's of that sort however the
whole point of governance it is in fact
designed to be the thing that addresses
the problematic you were just discussing
right and so the whole point is actually
the recursion or the microcosmic
boundary where governance is is itself
subject to its own uh
and we'll call right now I guess I guess
we'll use closure I'm not quite sure if
I'm even using it right because that was
a lot he was put in there but the uh
sort of the failure conditions that
we're talking about and of course you
can then imagine that kind of an
infinite regress of okay we'll do the
government it's on governance and then
the governance on the governance on
governance just is there uh reason to
believe that there's actually a way to
uh find a loopback whereby that that
actually that whole meta system actually
has something like a higher level of
stability and and you and you raise them
a lot of different points in the very
beginning in terms of the three basic
questions of what the word stability
might even mean it might it might not
mean that it lasts forever in fact
rarely would it but it might mean that
it fails really interestingly so that
you know like like the biological
organism I die I don't live forever but
but my life might be part of a larger
Arc that has a completely different
continuity process and and that's
actually the thing that we're thinking
about the song I might die interestingly
and so that's a very different solution
to the basic problem right
um
okay what else was in there there was
something really really interesting
where I kind of tried to focus okay so
um I noticed also the the this uh the
I'll call it geometry so almost like the
the third mode so we discussed you
discussed the um you know a
characteristic and dissipative systems
where relationships between two
different structured possibility spaces
um produces a new
um architecture it actually produces
order at a purely physical level
and um and I would say this is something
like there's there's
principles of physics or principles of
nature that are as fundamental as
thermodynamics and because they're as
fundamental they constrain the playing
out of thermodynamics
um
and it's important to recognize we
actually have that that's in the toolkit
we can use this and one of the things
that I was thinking about is that that
one of the things that oftentimes shows
failure conditions in human Design
Systems is
vertical or horizontal asymmetry you
know so for example
if if I have like one person endeavoring
to govern but let's just use it actually
in business that we actually the
ordinary sort of business organization
the notion of span of control in
military and in and for all
bureaucracies it's pretty well
understood but if I have a manager or a
business governance function
um they generally can't actually govern
more than a small number of other people
right so if I have a single manager when
governance functioning they're
indifferent in governance say 500 000
people that asymmetry in terms of
information like I think in terms of
information Theory perception sense
making uh and effective Choice making
that can be actuated down will create a
wide variety of gaps and niches for
parasitism but
maybe there's something to be found in
the context of a proper geometry where
the information asymmetry is inside of
some sort of of conscious boundary like
we came to think about in terms of
what's actually possible in terms of the
space of Consciousness how we can
produce larger spaces of Consciousness
and then how we can actually design
information flow through within that
space so that every
um
[Music]
every flow is actually held within
within a governance envelope that
doesn't produce these niches for
parasitism
yeah yeah I mean 100 that's very
resonant I think that
in that context so so to pick apart this
this is symmetry asymmetry question a
bit more
this relates to you know there's sort of
a long line of uh or undercurrent of
political science that's not that not as
popular that sort of flows through you
know like Machiavelli mosca Burnham you
know that that vein of just pointing out
the the
side effects of this kind of asymmetry
with respect to the idea of leadership
or sort of the ratification of any
system uh in so far as it must take
place within a subset of the population
it can't be like even the idea of
democratic governance itself has to be
acted out on the day-to-day by a
fraction of the entire group uh on
behalf of which is being played out in
theory and so that that subset of people
who are identified
um
are then you know they become
responsible for for enacting that game
with a particular degree of integrity
and I think that that concept of
Integrity this is really this kind of
relates to the maybe the quality of
those governance envelopes you're
talking about in the structure uh but
also the scope and scale over which uh
perhaps responsibility is one way of
thinking about it but then also
accountability because I think to some
extent that accountability transparency
game and to the extent more and more
people are playing off out their lives
uh while trusting you to do the right
thing especially you know part of that's
going to mean that more of their
resources are falling into you with that
trust which increases the incentives for
you to potentially uh do something that
they will not see you know while their
eyes are directed elsewhere it's kind of
like I like to use the game of you know
if there's a the more money that's in
the pot on the table right the more you
have to be careful going to the bathroom
during the game if everyone leaves the
room and you just leave one guy in there
uh you know you got to be a little bit
careful because even if that's a very
trustworthy person at that table you
know it the larger that puck gets you
know you start beginning to trust uh to
test that that degree of integrity and
that's kind of that that same asymmetry
is like the better system of government
the best systems of governments that
create the more of the systems we create
to generate value if they are actually
successful it is exactly that value
that's created by them that becomes the
Temptation for defection and and and so
this is very interesting with respect to
this envelope question because it it
transforms into this accountability and
representation question I think uh and
to the extent that we are forced to
represent these systems or to have
accountability with these systems I
think we live in a very interesting time
because we are beginning to be able to
have uh you know representative
granularity and transparency in ways
that were never before possible
even and then and using those to sort of
act as proxies for maintaining integrity
and binding constraints on people's
behavior and it's an interesting balance
because we obviously you know if someone
is a representative uh we want those
people to enact the highest ideal in
theory of their representative position
uh that being said uh we also need to
have that position be somewhat
attractive and uh to the extent that
anyone is is is looking to
act out that position if it is fully
constrained and surveilled they might no
longer be interested in taking on that
position so you see you might have to
you know one solution to that might be
something along the lines of like well
automate the whole thing
but but humans don't like as embodied
beings humans don't tend to respond well
to the idea of an abstract entity that
they don't really fully understand the
internals and that kind of aren't
actually hitting our mirror neurons in
the right way either like we're not
getting that reflective property of like
yes I intuitively understand this thing
I think we get also innately suspicious
whenever the idea of some sort of
abstract system uh you know acting as
our representative or acting as our
governance even if that were fully
transparent and less likely to defect
against us or provably would not defect
against us like we might just rebel
against it anyway so we there's sort of
this possible Catch-22 there so so those
are some I guess some thoughts there
yeah that's interesting so
oh that that one that last piece
it's let me see how that's right
the last piece which was called the AI
governance piece
um
it's kind of there's no kind of worthy
it's tremendously worthy of a really
serious Deep dive and maybe sooner
rather than later right we're actually
accelerating in the direction where that
kind of Science Fiction narrative is
um plausibly and let's not say like we
don't know these things happen in Step
functions they don't tend to go in a
straight a curve uh but plausibly is on
the Event Horizon so we may actually
have to wrestle with that I would
propose though I cannot prove it
um with adequate rigor and so it would
require a collaborative effort but I
propose that is in fact that idea can't
work and there's actually I believe an
actual rigorous proof that is available
that the notion of a fully automated
government system is intrinsically
unstable but that doesn't mean that we
won't try to do it and trap ourselves
thereby
um so let me let me back up a little bit
before we get there because we can talk
about the stuff that's sort of in
between and uh this is very much the
tainter the tanter story more or less
right so we get we get the idea of um
so the first movement is is the
relationship between contextualization
and decontextualization
um which may be the thing that humans
specifically most fundamentally do is
the ability to decontextualize we can
pull the Salient elements of some
particular landscape out as we see fit
right not just
um by virtue of evolutionary Fitness we
can actually fluidly identify
characteristics that we'd like to pop
into the foreground and sort of reify
down into principles and then most
specifically Endeavor to govern I.E to
optimize for or against or modulate
according to our own preferences
um and of course one of the things that
we can do with that power of
decontextualizations we can then design
architectures uh on the basis of that
decontextualization which is the the
term technology that's what that means
right technology is a the ability to
decontact use decontextualization to uh
design in nature uh phenomena that are
specifically optimizing for particular
principles
um that we've been able to pull out of
of what is otherwise a larger a larger
million
um and I would propose that this is at
the basis of both the strength and the
weakness of the the design like the
epoch of design and
the limitations of decontextualization
are very deeply woven into the fragility
or the problematic of say tantric style
curves the high all the things that
we're talking about so uh you know of
course in the process of
decontextualization on the one hand
we're able to identify What's called the
most the most relevant or the most
Salient characteristics of some system
and then we can begin to control for
them okay I want I want more calories
per unit yield of wheat
um but of course the the inverse is also
True by virtue of decontextualization we
move away from the ability to have high
quality perception of all of the other
things that are going on in that
embedded system so we lose track of them
and by virtue of losing track of them to
the degree to which they matter and of
course now we're getting into kind of
like uh
something around Heisenberg and deep
chaos theory meaning tiny tiny
differences microcosmic differences
possibly at the plank limit tend to
build up into large consequences so that
as we decontextualize we render into the
invisible we render out of the realm of
design out of the realm of the conscious
a whole bunch of things that were in
fact by definition calculated via
relevant relevance realization at the at
the unconscious evolutionary level just
by you know sheer actual having causal
effect on the system and then of course
we're setting ourselves up we're setting
ourselves up to have unintended
consequences Cascade out into our larger
environment and then what we tend to do
then this is the the tantric move the
thing that I want to kind of bring into
the into the foreground is that we tend
to double down so what we do is we will
briccollage or we will cluge new
technologies at the edge oh okay this
particular problem is showing up great
I'm going to do the same move I'm going
to look at that problem foreground or
Decon texture realize the elements that
I can identify in the problem
put together a new technology connected
to the previous technology we kind of
get one of these um remember building
mobiles when you're a kid you can kind
of add something at the balance point
and it can kind of layers layers down
um and of course the the point that
somebody like tainted very specifically
makes and I think [__] also maybe not
quite as clearly makes is that we then
get lost in our own creation right the
the machine that we have built is has so
much complicatedness to it it has so
much
um so many different things going on
that we're no longer actually able to do
Master of our own machine and this moves
us back into an unconscious design phase
right so now we're effectively
maintaining something that we don't
understand in many cases
Our Generations past its origin stories
we've actually you know we have a tiny
window of awareness in a much larger
field that larger field doesn't have the
advantage of a tightly coupled deeply
nuanced complex fully contextualized
characteristic instead it actually has
lots of these little decontextualization
gaps foregrounds and backgrounds but
we're super not aware of it if you've
lost track of it a lot and now this is
part of the niche environment every one
of those gaps becomes a niche for
various forms of parasitism or become
places where local entropy is is
collected and can't be addressed because
they're effectively in various kinds of
blind spots or in what what the Santa Fe
people would call Frozen accidents of
our own complicated Machinery I.E it's
just a gap that that arose because the
way that we built the control system and
for us to actually just address the Gap
we have to deconstruct the control
system but the game theory doesn't work
the cost of deconstructing the control
system is something that we're not
willing to do to so the local entropy
just gathers and gathers and gathers
until it festers and it eventually
creates a breakage that we sort of
unconsciously just accepted as what's
going to happen
um
okay I think that that sort of played
out what I had there
I can hear you by the way I'm just gonna
get some more water
okay yeah no problem no problem
um yeah and and so
I mean that that obviously ties into the
dynamic of you know sort of at the more
colloquial level the fact that uh that
humans don't act in general creatures
biological organisms but especially
humans that are in theory through one
lens
known to be the kind of creature that
attempts to to look into the the future
The Horizon of possibility and and
attempt to act in line with uh a manner
in which that that feature uh remains
habitable let's say uh but then there's
always this long-term short-term tension
with respect to you know at what point
does the you know do the do the possible
thresh do the potential threats start to
uh realize themselves or actualize
themselves at levels that generate
sufficient uh sufficient you get to call
entropy or suffering or you know
something that sort of shakes you
strongly enough to to actually or deeply
enough to change Behavior or your frame
of reference at the appropriate uh scale
to produce transformation that uh can
respond to whatever that blind spot that
you're mentioning by the process of
decontextualization uh whatever that
whatever has been manifesting in that
blind spot that is then threatening the
Integrity of the process or the the
capacity of that process to to maintain
continuity across time one thing that
really struck me that's interesting as
well and I think yeah I guess I've been
playing around with a lot of these types
of ideas lately in terms of uh with
respect to words and the the sort of
inversion capacities or cyclic
capacities of taking a concept and and
flipping it and seeing what happens this
idea of decontextualization is
fascinating to me because you know
when you're discussing it uh in my mind
something that's popping up is is
another like way of looking at this very
phenomenologically is that if you if we
look at ourselves as categorizing beings
attempting to attempting to and to me
what categorizing beings tends to mean
is is having a functional attractor of
some sort that we're binding
representations to with this sort of
agglomerative tendency of more and more
things that have that likeness or
sameness or are associated with that
network uh building over time
um one of the the essential
characteristics is that we can't focus
on everything at a given point in time
and therefore we have to live inside a
given framework that mediates
facilitates and and hones our
attentional capacity to actually
navigate that process of of using this
category structure to relate to
actualities and possibilities
continuously across time and so
interestingly enough
the context of that ambiance and one way
of looking at decontextualization might
also be a process of hyper
contextualization in the sense where we
are taking a very small representative
Subspace uh we're identifying a
particular set of Concepts like you know
I think abstraction is a way of looking
at this right like you're saying there's
a set of similarities here and they're
graspable enough within my mind at the
moment so I'm going to take those and
then begin to act as if I'm living
inside those as the full context right
and so like through that zooming in to
the abstraction or to that to that
subset of the possible pattern space I
begin to act as if that subset is the
entire Ambiance and therefore become
blind to everything that is not inside
that Subspace and so you're sort of
living inside the Micro Niche this micro
gradient because you identified a useful
gradient inside that abstraction for
some uh some perhaps instrumental or or
even you know even something that was
truly convincing like
um you know the idea of calculus is
extremely compelling and we got a great
deal of adaptive utility out of that
concept but does it hit a limit at some
level in terms of like the metaphors and
the way of seeing the world through the
lens of calculus does it start to break
down I mean I would argue yes I think
there there are boundaries when you
start to see the world as a set of
instance when with respect to my studies
in Consciousness and and like the
emergence of Consciousness and topology
of Consciousness I think one of the
things that actually has done you know
inhibits us quite a bit is trying to
think of it as an instantaneous property
of a system something that could in
theory be pointed out as a as a a point
on a tangent curve somewhere right like
um so in any case like this recontextual
decontextualization Frame I think is a
very deep frame and and part of this
phenomenological tendency we have to see
patterns and then start living with
inside those patterns as an Adaptive
framework and then just to close this
off I guess with respect to the coonian
take on that as well you know in his
he's well known for structural
scientific revolutions but my favorite
essay by [__] is uh an essay called the
essential tension which is like the
essay in which she kind of responds to
the public response to his structure of
Scientific Revolution speaking in front
of I think it was the APA or something
like that at the time and you know
saying
I essentially have been largely
misinterpreted by people who want to use
that work as a justification for
throwing off all constraints but in
reality what he was saying this
essential detention was like uh there's
a frame that's established a very formal
rigid frame and the point of that formal
rigid frame and discipline is to move to
a point of convergence not because of
the convergence point is the
transcendental ideal that we absolutely
must get to but because by acting as if
that convergence process is worth
um worth moving toward as we converge we
will realize what is outside of that
cone of convergence so to speak it'll
start showing up as aberrations and then
by collecting those aberrant pieces of
information we can begin to realize oh
okay this is how we can print in a
principled and structured and continuous
manner uh once again open that frame
back up
um
recontextualize the decontextualization
or or like Zoom back out of that hyper
Focus contextualization
um and and synthesize a new frame that
doesn't just jettison the value of the
previous frame uh arbitrarily but that
also isn't myopically focused Beyond a
point of critical uh uh uh critical
collapse let's say
um on pursuing that singular
interpretation of the the old frame and
so I think to some extent like this is
the set of patterns that were that we're
trying to work with when we talk about
and we're we're trying to one I think
we're we're instead of the structure
scientific
revolutions were like beginning to see
you know is it we're beginning to see
the traces of like the necessity of that
analogous process occurring at the
structural level of governance and and
this this is sort of the Zeitgeist of
our ERA with many people attempting to
to place ideas Place new frame
possibilities and which how should we
direct our attention uh into the the
space of public discussion and uh
hopefully experimentation and try to
figure out
um can we get some positive signals so
that as this prior frame begins to
disintegrate
um are there are there lifeboats that
are actually capable of carrying more
than one to five people at a time
yeah so
um it's notable that that uh you know
tanter referred to it as the collapse of
complex societies and
um I think the proper way of describing
what [__] was describing was not so much
of paradigm shift as a paradigm
catastrophe and
um I think there's a very specific point
there we're actually looking for
Paradigm Shift you know it's like hey I
got a paradigm okay now it's time to
shift in that movement and I I would
like to very much evoke here the uh uh
cognitive science Notions of opponent
processing and how the brain very
specifically in you know all the way
down to the most basic animals uses
modal distinction specifically what I
was thinking about is very much the
dynamic we're okay where it's time to
focus on a very localized task but
there's something happening at a meta
level
that allows and requires in fact is
Shifting back to diffuse and then moving
back and forth right and that that
notion of modal distinction right brain
left brain distinction are qualitatively
different in how they go about uh
orienting towards where to allocate
attention and even how to do
um sense making in the relationship to
perception and then there's a meta
Dynamic that moves back and forth
between them right so that kind of a
tricameral structure
um at a very very deep modal distinction
or qualitatively distinct level seems
like it's uh the proper design for any
kind of new kind of collective
intelligence
and uh I was brought to mind of the of
the distinction between thinking and
simulated thinking that I was trying to
make gosh about five years ago
um and I think that was that was
oftentimes also not fully grasped so if
you wouldn't mind I'll just recapitulate
because the point is very specifically
the point
um
that we have we have very we have two
modes at least but definitely two modes
of thinking right one mode that I called
habit mode one mode that I called
explore mode and I was I'm not
necessarily trying to say that I
invented any of this and there are many
people I'm sure have done a much better
job I was trying to point out the thing
I'm trying to point out is not that
um but the idea that habit mode like
Paradigm is able to take advantage of a
variety of different Frameworks that are
relatively well designed for a
particular domain and therefore quickly
and accurately and predictably be able
to make sense and select appropriate
choices in the context of a certain
domain right that's a very functional
thing to have explore mode is a mode
that is modally distinct has a more
diffuse awareness much more contextually
aware is oriented towards things like
Insight I.E breaking existing
assumptions and very very oriented
towards the subtle things that may not
ordinarily be noticed in habit mode but
may actually be relevant and that's why
we have to have this different Explorer
right so the The Meta process is okay
which mode should I be in right now am I
am in a context where Explorer mode is
the most adaptive mode or am I a context
for habit mode is the most adaptive mode
and can I fluidly move back and forth
right so that's that that third right so
I've got one two three and the premise
of this notion of simulated thinking is
that there's something about habit mode
where we can get stuck in it so it
somehow habit mode breaks this third
governance layer that allows us to
fluidly move back and forth and then
gets us more and more stuck in habit
mode in particular where we begin to
build a habit that simulates governance
right and then and then we're in trouble
because at that point we can't actually
make proper use of explore mode
because we actually haven't got the
capacity all we can do is when the
governance system is saying hey it's
time to move to explore mode habit mode
says oh I've got it and then produces
something vaguely like explore mode but
still within the fundamentals of habitat
and you can you can sort of
extend that to all the different
examples we've used right this operates
in every Dynamics you know so in Coon's
model it would be anomalies are being
thrown and the larger system is saying
hey there's something wrong with our
Paradigm but but the the paradigmatic
mind says well I'll just produce a more
complex version of my existing Paradigm
to absorb those anomalies into it or
I'll use the function of ignoring in
other words I'll put them into a an area
of local entropy and just kind of let
them sit for however long maybe forever
ideally right and the you know the meta
premise is that's the problem right that
is the problem of conscious design is
that getting stuck and not actually
having the opponent processing built
robustly enough that we can move from
habit into Explorer without having to go
through a crisis right the problem is is
not that we sometimes our habits aren't
functional we have to move to a
different mode the problem is sometimes
we get addicted to our habits and the
only we can get out of them is actually
to go through hitting rock bottom and
that's a very very un adaptive way of
solving that kind of problem
so yeah yeah and um and just to sort of
like to
test the language a bit and make sure
that I'm I'm with you here and uh also
use it potentially to synthesize some of
the the topics that we've been talking
about
um
it's fascinating to consider this in
light of of this question so in terms of
parasitism that we've been talking about
and also the question of uh the benefits
of parasitism possibly right because
you're talking about this this
catastrophic or this catastrophe which
is in you know dynamical systems in many
ways analogous to to to falling off a
cliff
um like in the map that is actually
exactly like that anyways
um and so uh
it could be it could be the case right
that one way of looking at parasitism if
you can if you can endogenize it or if
you can actually internalize some amount
of it or look at it as a property of
systems is is potentially as a smoothing
function for that Cliff insofar as you
know this gradient that we were talking
about before
um in light of the language you're
talking about
in terms of uh this habit mode right and
exploration mode uh with respect to
Collective governance or Collective uh
systems used for simulating this
adaptive process as a collective
um that Collective process of governance
can at times be in that exploration mode
potentially discovering some new form so
if you you look at like the Inception of
our you know the nation of the United
States and there's a lot of synthesis
happening a lot of different ideas you
know from a you know lineage you know
extending thousands of years into
history uh drawing from all of that to
try to synthesize a particular novel
framework
um it was very conscious hyper-conscious
hypersynthetic very exploratory
um but it created something that in its
stability and efficacy became so
functionally stable that more and more
people were able to move into habit mode
with respect to that as a foundation and
as that happens uh interestingly enough
it opens up uh little exploratory niches
for actors to go in and say are there
micro gradients in that system because
of the fact that all these people are on
habit mode no longer their attention is
focused outwards it's no longer you know
a 10 ending inwards and so they actually
go in and and start siphoning energy
perhaps uh in their own Explorer modes
as perhaps parasitic Behavior Uh from
this governance Loop but interestingly
enough that can focus uh that can
function as a way of um testing the
stability of that Loop to some extent
like they are uh
forcing that fundamental functional
closure of governance that people have
stopped attending to on Moss generally
uh they're forcing it to operate under
additional constraints under additional
load even though that load like that's
an internal load that it might not have
necessarily been formally designed to
Bear but that parasitism you know like a
parasite load on any animal is forcing
that animal to operate
um over and above what they would have
to do otherwise without that parasitic
load and so it's actually building some
slack into the system perhaps such that
when people when people when we start
when things start getting shaky and
people turn their attention back into
that system see the parasites and
potentially get rid of them there's
still enough slack left in that
mechanism hopefully to navigate uh the
the cliff or you know to smooth the
cliff so that's like a possibility I'm
not really I'm not sure how coherent
that was if that made sense I mean let
me know but
it maps to I believe pretty almost
exactly to Brett Weinstein's um story
about uh peacock Tales of pyramids
so his argument this is effectively
peacock tails and pyramids are exactly
what you're talking about the defective
of the peacock Tails not just a pure
sort of sexual display but it's actually
effectively a parasitic Reservoir that
provides a Fail-Safe that to the degree
to which the context no longer supports
it you can lose a lot of [__] tail
get back a huge amount of adaptive
capacity without losing any real
holistic
um total uh Fitness and respond to
what's happening same thing with
pyramids like if you put a lot of social
uh
excess would that be called Surplus into
pyramids as opposed to say for example
more people
your carrying capacity is actually
buffered so that if there's actually a
significant uh drought where food
production is not as high as it was you
just stop building as many pyramids and
you don't actually have a cash problem
collapse of the underlying deep
structure was that in his thesis or I
haven't heard him talk about that uh
surprisingly I've heard him before
so I may have just added them I
apologize for some reason I thought it
was like I was like yeah because
um in the hunter-gatherers guide that
one or yeah and uh maybe I I've haven't
watched I don't know I need to reflect
back on it I don't it didn't yeah it
might be there but um yeah that's it
precisely yeah I mean it's certainly not
surprising to be like Brett and the mind
that Brett has in the way that he thinks
uh I think you and I tend to dovetail
and converge to a lot of similar frames
of reference so that's yeah but I mean I
think precisely that these abilities to
um maintain higher carrying capacities
within any given system fundamentally
provide slacking in that system and you
know we look at it if we look at it just
at the object level and and you know
through almost entirely moral framework
uh then uh it can it can it can lead us
to believe that there's no benefit here
and to perhaps be a little bit overly
acerbic in our language toward what's
going on interestingly enough it might
have been selected for we might be
selected precisely uh you know in the
same way that it's we have some
interesting side effects of psychopathy
that might have uh overall adaptive side
effects that small levels in society uh
some element of sort of corruption and
parasitism uh at a base level within
even healthy systems might be optimal
um to the extent we can talk about
optimality in such a system and so
um and that might and then knowing that
might uh my bravest against becoming
overly cynical right
um because I think that at some levels
the at some level the the greatest
threat to our current capacity for
adaptation uh is a abundance of cynicism
uh and an abundance uh and like
innervating quality of that cynicism
with respect to to sapping us of the the
necessary will energy and belief that
that we can actually do anything that is
uh that is worth doing so nice Daniel
how much time do we have left
25 minutes but I'm happy to stay on
anytime you want to feel free to
continue this section and then we can go
into q a
I have another piece that I'd love to
drop in right here
um so let's see yeah
the psychological consequences of being
stuck
and
um
almost like the psychosocial
consequences like the feedback loop so
on the one hand you have the interior
psychology of being in something like
simulated thinking
um where you can't get out of your own
habits of of thought and you can't
escape into a higher level of insight
you can't escape back into explore mode
but also the feedback loops are being
stuck in a collapse and complex society
where uh explore mode is in fact
inhibited because it doesn't have any
place to get energy or resource for
example or positive feedback the energy
resource and all the different human
needs modalities and so what happens
when you're in there and what happens
there is you start getting things like
you get depressed
um you get cynical you get nihilistic
you get anemia right
um
okay so let me think okay I'll do it
three things first that notion of
parasitism as a as a reservoir of
potential is very interesting and I can
think about that immediately in in two
ways two examples that pop up uh one is
that the notion of like eighty percent
85 of people are in so-called [__]
jobs or at least self-reported
um which I think is very very reasonable
particularly if you sort of think about
the Cascade effects
um meaning if you were to remove a whole
category of [__] jobs you would
realize there's a whole other set of
jobs that are actually [__] jobs
produced entirely by the first category
so if you start unwinding them well on
the one hand that's terrible right I
mean people are wasting their lives and
their energy and just spinning on the
other hand oh that's really good because
that actually means that I've got sort
of 80 of the human population is sitting
on the sideline waiting to be deployed
generatively as soon as we can get our
head out of our ass right that's nice to
catch both ways
um I also recall during the the
2008-2010 financial crisis
I'm saying okay well how far down does
this system actually call it need to
fall for truly robust reset I.E if the
too big to fail systems have been
allowed to fail properly which is what
should have happened what would that
have looked like
it's like well we're probably not going
to drop below like a 1972 level of
standard of living like that's a pretty
big fall from where we are right now and
I recall the 1972 was actually pretty
nice and it wasn't a terrible style of
life and the point being that there's
almost something like the uh what are
they called the like the F-350 hyper
truck well it turns out that if if we
have to actually give up our F350 and
just scale back down to an F-150 oh
that's actually not that bad we'll
survive that's not that's not a
catastrophe right that's actually a
pretty decent amount of fat built into
the system that we can allow to cut back
and not lose our [__] now the challenge
of course is can we do that elegantly so
then I'll get to the third piece
um everything that I'm about to say is
from my opponent is entirely
hypothetical I am making up this story
on the basis of some some heuristics but
the the notion is something like this
kind of dynamic of
um modal uh uh opponent processing and
some kind of system that that catalyzes
the movement back and forth between them
is is very very old like deeply
fundamental it's too important not to be
woven in like the obviously the
sympathetic sympathetic nervous system
um go way back all right so that basic
structure is super fundamental and shows
up all over the place all right second
humans at the at the kind of the first
apoc indigenous humans almost certainly
therefore would have used that at the
social level right we would not have
been able to achieve something like a
social cultural style of collective
intelligence that didn't also have this
kind of structure woven and deeply but
it would have been woven in deeply
using embodied cognition obviously not
design cognition because we weren't at
the design recognition apoc so what does
that mean what does it look like the
proposition is something like
when the external context when the
conditions that we're in
are signaling a need to move to a group
explore mode exiting paradigmatic
obligate paradigmatic mind or stuckness
exiting habit mode into a more liminal
form of collective intelligence
there's a every distinct human at an
embodied level will sense that
differentially
and they will subtly begin to signal
that differentially back into the
collective environment I'll give that
concrete and so
um
it's been raining less and less
we don't have concepts of of rainfall we
don't have meteorology like there's a
long [__] time ago but we notice in a
very fundamental sense our bodies are a
little bit more dehydrated or the energy
necessary to get water a little bit
higher we're noticing the prey animals
are reduct are not as common we're
noticing that uh yield of food is
decreasing noticing at the physical
level deep deep stuff like biological
and then there's different types of
humans right we have a different
typology we have old women we have young
women we have young men we have children
we have older men right there's all and
probably I'm guessing something on the
order of like
7 to 40 cognitive typologies that cover
the different
um kind of modes of reality that it's
useful to have strengths and weaknesses
in it right so this is a there's a
collective intelligence that the
indigenous level is constructive
typological differences each of those
typological differences will have
differentials and sensitivity to the
subtle signals of is it time for us to
actually move to a new Niche do we need
to leave the valley and go into the
mountains because the rainfall is
telling us that flood time is about to
come that kind of thing right and it
will show up in Behavior that's the key
thing like actual physical behavior
um physical Behavior will produce a
second order feedback loop right as I
notice the older women behaving in a
different way it signals me in an
embodied level to begin and the ACT adds
additional differential signal to my own
perception
and then we'll change my behavior and so
when I'm noticing for example that the
young women are giving attention and
perhaps sexual access to a different
kind of behavior in men very clearly
this will change the behavior in young
men but that also will cause to tend to
Cascade throughout the larger
environment so the idea is there's
something like a a very very complex set
of multi-typological feedback loops
pulling in subtle information from the
context that will eventually catalyze a
pivot from
tribal paradigmatic locked in very
functional and effective adaptive habit
mode into okay let's all sit around the
fire hand off the comp from the chief to
the shaman let's talk about the oldest
deepest mythological stories hey Elders
are you aware of anything like a very
different mode right
um the premise I'm making is that that's
actually the case I'm going to argue
that we have that that a large part of
what's actually going on like
characteristics like depression and
cynicism are
feel like frustration you know how
frustration works right frustration is
when there's a deeply felt sense that
there needs to be some change in the
world that is building up energy to make
the change but the change can't the path
to the change can't actually be produced
and the energy effectively feeds back on
itself right that's the energy of
frustration which eventually will either
build to a release this way or it will
uh come to a feed it'll cut itself up to
the source and then it will lead to more
like depression right so
that's a proposed like to put out there
that we're in a moment a big part of
what's going on is that we're all
receiving the signal that we need to
shift into this
um Collective Consciousness mode this
liminality mode this this group explore
mode we don't know how and we're largely
stuck and so we're trying to figure out
how to make that move at very micro
level like there's lots and lots of
adaptive stuff going on not the least of
which is the Brokenness of our body mind
our body is in our mind in relationship
to just reality ideology overriding our
signals like in body cognition is way
out of whack
um and a big big chunk maybe even like
90 of the chunk of the problem they're
actually dealing with is the Journey of
Simply restoring ourselves to that basic
capacity once we get back to that basic
capacity unlocking the 80 of people who
are sitting in [__] jobs back into a
coherent collective intelligence that's
operating in a group explore mode
has enough capacity to actually navigate
us to the niche we want to get to so
that's a
I've taken the problem of governance and
say okay that's actually we can take a
series of steps and think about how do
we maybe find a way to work our our path
how do we find the path to get us back
to the location where we regenerate our
ambient indigenous capacity to operate
in this mode from which we should unlock
a vastly larger capacity to think about
these bigger problems right and the end
of point
yeah I mean there's there's a lot there
I think I you know I could go I could go
on a
I I I'm quite the response I don't I
think in terms of time though I I think
Daniel you did want to bring in some
live chat questions as well
um or in terms of where do we want to go
here because I could I could respond to
that there's a lot of really interesting
points there uh or we could weave
questions into that uh that context that
frame
um where do you want to go
Matthew with a direct response then
um we'll have a rapid question and
answer that'll take us just around the
time that we agreed upon and feel free
to depart as well and then at the very
end I'll just make some Reflections and
connect it to active inference so first
Matthew then question and then feel free
to stay or leave and they'll be a little
active reflection
cool yeah and in light of that I was
also really wanting to raise some of the
uh the active inference uh semantics and
context in response to in response to uh
Jordan's points
um one interesting frame that he'll it's
interesting to observe that it hasn't
saturated the culture perhaps just given
the mimetics of when and where is
introduced but
um sort of like EO Wilson and uh Edward
Lumsden introduced something called dual
inheritance Theory uh 20 to 30 years ago
I'm not sure if you you
encountered that they had this book
called uh genes mind and culture and um
there's a lot of residents with respect
to the mechanisms you know they did a
lot of work with respect to the manner
in which the kind of uh diversity of the
behavioral sensitivities
um psychological psychomomatic and like
cultural level sensitivities and
behavioral patterns uh have these kind
of emergent feedback loops that uh that
essentially end up creating a emergent
form of parametrization at the cultural
level and the cultural Dynamics you know
these changes you're talking about at
deeper levels of reality as they bubble
up through and restructure the cultural
manifestations and the sensitivities uh
and behavioral Tendencies of this
diversity of psychotypes I guess you you
were saying how that actually as a as a
mechanism feeds back into uh and back
down through all those other different
layers of adaptive uh mediation
selection transformation
um and sort of like this this emergent
Cascade and then this essentially
reflects the parameters parameterization
which many people have struggled with in
the fat in the past is under the offices
of the argument around downward
causation that's a whole slightly
different conversation but I do think
active inference is very interesting
um
from the perspective at least from my
perspective some of the work I've been
doing recently
showing that in many ways uh active
inference is in it offers a one one
function in the category the necessary
category of transformational mappings
between perception and action that do
exist at this deeply fundamental level
uh in terms of the the sort of
establishment of any causal closures
either you know you know of any
non-trivially complex uh process any any
cycle that's capable of observation and
action based on perception right in
relation to perception
um and interestingly I think that that
does biasure nature in the way that it
connects to itself give rise to this
bimodal topology like through a
particular kind of non-orientability and
so the reflectivity when something comes
back to you has a different orientation
so you actually have an understanding of
um you know the relationship between
past and present via the lens of
duration because of the need to perceive
and then impose some transformation on
the environment through that I think
we're just beginning to develop
the the capacity to
work with those tools in a way that
doesn't uh impose that that's more like
surfing these adaptive waves that allows
us to observe the way in which these
Transformations and perceptions are
mapping onto actions and using that as a
tool and and a potential in a toolkit of
like explicitly and consciously
designing networked connections between
these many different perceivers and
actors and their perceptual and action
capacities in a way that can um
I don't want to say provably but but but
prince in a principled manner give rise
to emergent systems that do have these
properties built in endogenously and
perhaps these signaling mechanisms built
in endogenously in ways that can
resonate with what you're talking about
which is the embodied sense that we have
intuitively or unconsciously that arises
but we don't necessarily have the
language or the framework to explicitly
talk about it so sort of that that that
emergent welling up of emotion or
frustration or depression or enemy as
you said
um
gets shunted into Language and Cultural
symbols and representations that don't
fully close back on the on the sort of
actuation capacities that we need to
actuate or that we need to upregulate in
this particular moment and I think
active inference and and other uh
Frameworks like it precisely because
they take this
perspective epistemic perspective that
says actually you don't get to directly
observe the world all you can do and the
best you can do is take this humble
process of of trying the best you can to
connect signals of perception to signals
of action in relationship to preferences
at a given time and the context in which
they exist and and build from there uh
ground up I think it's it's a leading
candidate in the the modes of
phenomenologically Shifting our
perspective through
um you know through new ways of
operating and seeing the world through
new paradigms through uh new toolkits so
you know that's why I think I've been
you know really interested in the active
inference space and see it as as
something that's quite relevant to this
entire conversation and in particular to
to your sort of final remarks there
all right excellent
awesome thanks both for the dialogue
this is really great so uh I will try to
bring in
many of the questions that were asked in
the very
active and energetic live chat
um
will get pretty quick thoughts that will
conclude the primary section of the
stream and then if you want to stay or
leave but I'll just add a few more
points because indeed the connection
with active inference is very Salient
okay so into the questions we go first
from Charles Bloss hello
what are the primary patterns including
values of wise collaboration
one was the one that you just noticed
which is moving at the pace
of wise collaboration meaning in this
case I noticed that's a very complex
question
I'll have to take a lot of time to think
about it yeah
questions raised yeah we raise the
questions here and explore it in the
coming time but feel free to give a
short response while you can
for sure for sure I mean it's just
interesting I think there's a continent
there because one of the things that was
coming to mind as I was taking the time
to try to reflect on that was was
patience hey especially in light of all
of the tendencies that shift us away
from the capacity to take in sufficient
information relation uh uh to cycle on
that in in a uh to to
so there's a tendency to always want to
especially under pressure under stress
to always want to take perception and
immediately map to action right like for
every cycle of perception some sort of
symmetric action because it feels very
it feels uh like you're at least doing
something feels better than doing
nothing but uh there might be some
minimal necessary amount of reflection
you might need to cycle a number of
times uh at a number of scales with a
diversity of opinions before the
capacity is built up in that Collective
um intelligence or Collective coherent
structure before any action that it
takes externally can do anything other
than make things worse and I think that
that's a massive problem that we're
confronting right now because most of
our tools are designed to map perception
to some sort of extrinsic action almost
instantaneously and we haven't created
the infrastructure that allows us to
more deeply uh allow for complex
emergent perception and mediated
mediated in the context of action at the
sort of duration and depth required to
meet the moment
great so then a follow-up comment and
then a question so Charles followed
speaking of time flagging an inquiry in
regard to timekeeping and calendars and
their specific numerics effects on
Humanity's psyche and cultures related
to this patience and Kronos and Kairos
um next question from Nathan Curtis
at what point in time from instantiation
does the established government lose its
ability to be self-referential and able
to look in on itself to identify flaws
I've had it I've had a general thought
about this question
um what I would say of course is that
the answer is is it depends right so the
particulars matter
um and I think it's going to be
something like three primary
characteristics
one isn't going to actually have to do
with the let's call the shape or the
topology of the underlying architecture
so an architecture like say liberalism
has a decent number of uh designed
fail-saves
very specifically conscious consciously
aware of this problem and so it has a
it's more like a dissipative structure
it has a higher capacity to actually
live longer given a particular gradient
we're using the earliest language we
were using
[Music]
um
the second it's funny you can actually
you can basically identify three very
straightforward principles and one is
the the amount of of energy or the
amount of of information or or potential
that was enclosed in the initial uh
design the second is the the
intelligence or Elegance of design in
terms of its actual uh ability to
produce structure that most effectively
uh
navigates that that dissipation into
entropy the third and this is I think a
piece that we're running into a lot is
something like a characteristic of
bandwidths
distinct from time meaning the proper
measure is not chronological time
Chronos but it's something like
relational interactions or Loops of
perception to agency something like that
and so if I think Jose is a kind of a
clock
um
that is the right clock
awesome yeah I mean that that Maps
directly onto you know kind of what I
was mentioning with respect to the
active inference idea of duration as
time right in the sense that that is
precisely that cyclic relation in terms
of perceiving the consequences of action
as perception and then you know
internally inside of whatever mechanism
is perceiving and acting at whatever
scale we're talking about
um you know that transformation is sort
of this this this era of time that we
perceive as as the linear structure that
linear mapping but the real time in a
lot of ways the systemic time is the the
path links through this causal structure
that flows
um between the action of Any Given
entity and uh the the capacity to
perceive feedback uh in terms of what
those actions caused and how that allows
you know in light of the contextualized
relations that give meaning to the
action in light of the values that are
ostensibly pursued and so in getting
back to the question in terms of when is
this system capable of or when does it
become no longer capable of of that kind
of self-reflection well I would say to
the extent that that cyclic time that
capacity that closure for being able to
understand the causal effects of one's
own actions in a contextualized
um
meaning grounded frame to the extent
that that is intercepted or broken right
um
or to the extent that it becomes no
longer concerned with its own
or solipsistic is another way of putting
it so those would be conditions right
it's like to the extent that it actually
uh becomes so
trapped in its own existing frame or its
own assumptions of causality
um so this would be you know in inactive
inference you know you have something
along the lines of
um you have something along the lines of
like an over
um like
the Precision of its its capacity to
represent the world becomes far too
precise with respect to the the the the
relationship between a very narrow
subset of modalities and factors in the
world percepts and actions in the world
which is exactly what we were talking
about earlier when we were talking about
in Jordan's language the
decontextualization or like hyper
contextualization
um and then you know that prevents you
from being able to identify
um a very large percentage of the causal
structure that might be relevant to
whatever is is threatening the coherence
of of your collective intelligence or
your actual physically embodied
metabolic systems or or whatever that
may be so
yeah
awesome Nathan bro
if we want those representatives to
embody a certain aspect of being in that
position how do we best select those
people what modalities can we use to
select the best AI recommendation
systems temperament and character
inventory test
I'm a person I'm fascinated by the
possibilities of uh emergent
identification
um of of reputation like networks that
take advantage of of
the information that exists in local
relationships uh we might notice that to
the extent that we have elections at
larger and larger scales we lose that
right like in your local elections in a
democratic election or Democratic
electorate
um you know if you're if you're voting
for uh for your county like you know for
for sort of like a county chair
um or a uh Governor or whatnot you're
much more likely to have relationships
uh or at least some sort of socially
contextualized understanding of of who
that person is and what the words that
are coming out of their mouth actually
mean in relationship to your embodied
life
um but the further you get away from
that the more you're dealing with
abstractions and so the more energy has
to be put into making those abstractions
feel real to you and then you enter the
world of you know television news and
political uh news Cycles very myopically
focused hyper precise a lot of energy
and time put into those particular
issues that get the most attention as
opposed to those issues that tend to
actually have a more embodied effect on
on you know an individual so how do you
actually take advantage or Surface that
that emergent pattern of contextualized
wisdom not just within Democratic
elections but at at a much deeper level
than we've ever considered before
because I think
One requirement of meeting the level of
complexity of the problems before us is
representing a much greater degree of
information which without that
information uh you know and that
information being at many scales of our
net emergent organism being the nation
state let's say for now
um without that information flow through
the system overwhelming the system I
think liquid democracy perspectives as a
general category are quite interesting
in terms of looking at them as as sort
of like graph finding or pathfinding
algorithms of expertise that are
mediated by local expertise or local
relationships local trust networks
um
trick with those is is I think executing
those in a way that is
um that is capture resistant that
doesn't necessarily make that doesn't
turn the entire game of life into a game
of of politics such that uh we are all
campaigning all the time to be perceived
as the greatest expert in whatever
domain without actually producing the
actions that would naturally give rise
to those perceptions it's a big problem
it's like aping aping the taping the
behaviors that would lead to someone
perceiving you as successful it's like
the Instagram model or Instagram
personality problem right it's like if
you rent the Jet Plane and you know put
on the facade and you wear the skin suit
and have the persona it's increasingly
difficult for a large percentage of
people to divorce that from the real
signal itself so I think within liquid
democracy uh patterns of sort of
emergent stewardship or identification
of people who might be able to solve
problems with greater competence that
emerges as a problem and then there's
also the problem of of response time so
it's like to some extent uh the reason
why we have Central executives are the
reason why we have individual
representatives and place Authority in
the hands of single individuals is
because there are particular kinds of
events that require response that is
at you know at the scale of smaller time
Windows than is typically capable with
um processes that include large numbers
of people so that's another attention uh
in terms of needing to solve that
without uh without falling back into
sort of the central executive idea but
those are just sort of the cluster of
thoughts that come into my mind when
that question arises
um what the first thing that come up for
me is that I would I would profoundly
caution that principle of asymmetry that
um
I'm reasonably confident that the right
way to do this is to almost perfectly
invert our current way of doing things
and our habits and intuitions meaning
um a radical regeneration of actual real
relationality and orientation of
sovereignty I.E Choice making Authority
and power to the lower level more
intimate locations is profoundly the
right way of doing things and so that
most people for the most most of the
time most of their choices are actually
being governed by high context Dynamics
um and then on top of that substrate you
then can actually relatively easily
build a construct that allows kind of a
distributed Cincinnatus where when it is
in fact very important to identify
individuals of extremely unique capacity
to deal with very specific problems that
aren't available within even a vaguely
large local environment
you can press them into it but the point
is that they're so deeply connected
80 of the time into a actual lived
context with all the different um how
does this like strong bond High feedback
loop high quality
subtlety that the capture into the
Instagram model thing it doesn't really
have it's obvious that that's a really
bad idea right if you have people who
are living almost entirely in Virtual
lives where there's really nothing real
in their lives that they don't actually
have real friends they don't have real
territory they don't have real
relationships with even like their
parents or their siblings then it's very
difficult for them to notice that the
Instagram influencer thing is terrible
right because they don't really have
something other than that that is
qualitatively distinct but if they're
actually living a truly healthy life
with all kinds of good positive things
happening then you can pop into this
other role notice that you really don't
want to live there do your job and get
the hell back into a a nurturing
environment
um I should mentioned by the way it's
not clear to me that we can actually get
from here to there air outside of
catastrophe right the navigation of that
particular path
um at the very least is a serious
serious serious job clearly well beyond
the capacities of anything that we have
right now so it would be kind of a
Tropic Cascade of a series of upgraded
capacities that get us to the point
where we have that capacity and you know
that's uh yeah good luck that was also I
think we've talked a little bit about
this or exchange a little bit about this
uh like on Twitter in terms of one of
one of those constraints and when you're
talking I just kind of wanted to get
your your take on this
um
one of those issues with respect to
potentially walking that adaptive uh
that adaptive Valley right or like
trying to balance upon that like
adaptive bridge line between our current
local Maxima and perhaps some sort of
you know foothold on uh on a on a larger
Fitness landscape um or higher point on
that Fitness landscape
um
is this idea of national capacity in
relation to the geopolitical structure
of the rest of the world right because
like we're operating not in isolation
we're operating you know if we if we
delegate uh if we delegate
responsibility like this transformation
that brings agency
outside of that Central locus of
coherence that is now this this Behemoth
The Leviathan of the state with its um
primary focus let's say or at least it's
ostensible reason for being as the
maintenance of the integrity and the
boundaries of the entity called the
United States or you know whatever the
nation might be at that scale if that
you know as soon as that sort of starts
to falter it's also perceived by other
agents on the landscape as opportunity
um and then interestingly enough is it
possible to maintain that transformative
traversal in light of whatever pressures
are added on top of our already great
list of pressures uh by other
geopolitical actors and I I suspect that
that's at least one possible reason why
you think that you know a transformation
like this will have to be forced out of
sort of a terrific Cascade collapse or
you know cascading collapses
um but yeah I'd be interested to hear
your take on on that
pyramids so by hypothesis
um let's say that the American Empire is
one giant peacock town and so we're
going to lose it but the good news is we
can't we can afford it in fact we better
off without it
um and so yes I think you're right the
the and it's funny it's almost like a
expanding to fill a niche right we found
ourselves in this odd circumstance of
being first a uh one of two superpowers
and then being an actual Global hegemon
for the very first time in human history
and we expanded to fill that Niche
meaning we we sort of depleted all of
our our excess capacity until we sort of
uh I'd say unconsciously and arbitrarily
sort of deployed the global hegemon game
all the way out to the edge right they
were sort of pushing at the absolute
limits of our control capacity uh and by
the way in the context of all these
other things we've been talking about
like local entropy and parasitism et
cetera and all the niches would open up
in that interior and I would simply
propose that we're already past that
point so uh one might argue that any
kind of change of behavior it comes with
cost of having to give up the benefit of
being a global hedge fund and maybe you
don't want to do that that's kind of the
taintor uh pivot point if you're
familiar with that point in the in the
arc
um how I think that dye has been cast
that we're right now in the process of a
forced uh Cascade down from that
position into some new multipolarity and
that can be and I suspect we've probably
gotten the order of like
three to five maybe seven more years for
that to kind of land all the way down
the land very clearly that that's where
we are but I would say we're past the
top of that point so it's a downhill
let's roll from there and much like this
notion of [__] jobs or the the
demoralization cynicism of being stuck
uh we might find ourselves demoralized
by being unrooted from being Global
hedge fund but we might also recognize
that was actually never a thing that
ever that we really really aspired to be
and could have been or should have been
more importantly could have been it was
doomed in from the very beginning and
that we're right now being forcibly
liberated from a highly dysfunctional
location which then if you sort of
shrink the scope back uh down to a much
smaller scope may actually produce a
large enough
um large x of of time and control
capacity to afford US called The
Generation a generation and a half to
re-establish a more generative
governance infrastructure so that's a an
interesting possibility at least it's a
nice story
wow okay we're gonna live a path
associated with that at least it's not
that path
something interesting
okay to ask a few more questions just
feel free to make sure I have to be very
careful with timing because my wife's
gonna be coming back with my
four-year-old and I have a immediate
responsibility so we can we can go but
be mindful I mean literally hit the red
button and be gone
sounds good please depart
um as family demands so just I'll read a
few more questions and then again I'll
just stay after to give a few
Reflections so what is a good example of
a major expanded decontextualization
that we live in that exists in the
culture now
expanded I didn't understand that a
major expanded decontextualization
maybe a broad scale okay
okay maybe that might be like a
synthesis of the the two ways that we
were talking about this and maybe in
terms of
expanded decontextualization and sense
of the the
hyper so the the tendency to see the
world uh maladaptively
um through a lens that has grown so ah
okay so large that we can see nothing
else perhaps the code policy
yeah covet policy is a great example of
exactly that right we we built a a
medical and
um Healthcare what is it called Public
Health infrastructure
pulling forward decontextualizing a very
large number of aspects of of about
embodied embedded humans and effectively
with that digits that put a series of
knobs in the cybernetic control
structure that when a real problem came
up that has extreme systemic complexity
the way we ended up dealing with it is
we started pulling these knobs as
opposed to addressing the underlying
systemic complexity we were like okay
lockdown why lockdown well lockdown may
be an optimal strategy if you think that
you could shut down the spreading of a
virus and are completely ignoring all
the other systemic consequences of
lockdown for example
it was kind of like a you go to war with
the Army you have philosophy except that
the control board we had was extremely
low resolution and even contraindicated
by our own past advice in many ways but
but it was at hand and so we pulled the
lovers
um even though there were plenty of us
who were saying you know perhaps
treating this as a giant light switch is
uh is not wise
um but isn't always the best play yeah
yeah and I would also just extend that
point into the the fact that beginning
to reflect on that as a society is also
showing us that there are a number of
other uh decontextualization or or sort
of like frame lock issues that we have
that are are quite uh that have built
quite up in a lot of inertia around them
especially around the domain of what we
call science or what is now parodied as
the science or uh scientism which is
like the slightly the more serious uh
conversation that's been going on since
the Advent of uh essentially early
post-modern philosophy in the van sort
of phenomenology like who Cyril and who
Cyril's questioning of uh of of sort of
the the paradigmatic uh nature of
science as a
way of seeing the world that can
displace all of our ways of seeing the
world if we're not careful and um
the tendency of that to because it has
provided such a again this is sort of
this this question of um exploration
finding uh capacity and then that
capacity to becoming so powerful that it
it puts people into habitual mode and
that habitual mode becomes a fallback if
other levels of social uh or
psychological or even mythopoetic
coherence break down so you know to the
extent that people lose other frames for
perceiving reality uh perhaps
for for interpreting their
phenomenological meaning which is you
know what the mythical poetic frame has
provided for so long uh to the extent
that breaks down sometimes for good
reason I mean again there's a lot of
corruption in the church and in religion
and there's a lot of I would say decay
in the sort of interpretive frames
presented uh to
um to upcoming Generations I mean I was
one of those people raised Catholic
um initially left the church became
essentially anti-theist for quite some
period of time before beginning to
realize only through evolutionary
education and looking at sort of the
game theoretic lens in terms of deep
history that you know there was
something there there was a there there
and that it wasn't necessarily something
we could jettison but many people have I
think many people were in that same
position and being in that position have
jettisoned in that frame falling back
upon the purely uh scientific frame but
not themselves doing science being
associated with the process therefore
falling into a dogma and being willing
to trust the high priest therefore
creating an incentive for high priests
who are mouthing the words and playing
the game of Politics as opposed to
really committed to the continued
process of discovery and transformation
and representation that we know is
science and uh you know getting
ourselves into that whole situation and
I think we're still a very live
conversation we're still trying to
figure this out and you know what is
What is the relationship between science
can you have a scientific exploration of
mythopolitic concert trucks I think
that's a really fascinating possible
field that also active difference would
have a lot to say in terms of the
emergent structure of collective
Behavior Uh that's sort of the same kind
of questions like really digging into
and beginning to examine the kind of
questions you were talking about earlier
with respect to what it means for
different people to have different
traits Tendencies of perception
personality traits what that ontology
looks like you're saying maybe 7 to 40
uh psychotypes or something like that
what the Dynamics of that as an
emergency system actually look like in
terms of their feedback and
parametrization on the underlying
structure and evolution of our society
and how mythogletic structures and
scientific perspectives change those
perceptions and interaction with one
another in Dynamic feedback mechanisms
with one another or dynamic feedback
relations with one another I mean these
are all questions for the next 50 years
right I mean yeah very important ones I
would say yeah so I I liked it for this
we're listening I like the fact that you
were actually in describing a
decontextualized uh camera the structure
but it's describing the structure you
also were articulating where a lot of
the failure conditions emerge and how we
find ourselves
um like this systemic shift like you
don't notice that you're actually moving
from science into politics or moving
from science into theology into politics
and because you don't even notice
there's a thing that could happen it's
not a risk that you're even
contemplating in your behavior and so
you're finding yourself on that on that
trajectory maybe the the mother of all
like who actually met a point being
where we are like nearing the end of
something the the short answer is to the
question is kind of everything
so everywhere you look is a
hypertrophied example of extended
decontextualization and so the problem
is actually being aware of what the
opposite might even look like
um but maybe the mother of all is
education the education system
I would say that the
um the current education system
decontextualizes humans it's a
development developing humans so
radically as to deprive them of probably
something between 70 and 90 percent of
Developmental needs which produces
probably a net yield of probably a 99
reduction in total human capacity
um and many of the things that that
Matthew was just bringing up like the
embodied facility not just not just the
cognitive scientific awareness of the
particular psychotypes and their
relationships but actually building
actual facility in navigating that
properly how you individually navigate
the world and how you can be in right
relationship with distinct other kinds
of humans in collaborative spaces
like that's actually really hard and
it's not the kind of thing that's easy
to learn when you're 50 right it's the
proper thing to be learning between the
ages of like four and twelve and then
deployed effectively in particular kinds
of contexts between say 12 and 20 like
so
um sorry that's a I'm doing the same
thing I'm pointing out the things we
don't even notice that we have lost my
virtue of becoming hyper hyper focused
on a very particular set of optimization
characteristics
and also education as I think a very
very big example of the of the basic
problem
yeah and I think that that form of
Education to the extent that we can do
that we can also begin to see you know
in light of what you're saying with
respect to uh it's almost everything at
this point a key element of that almost
everything is the economic domain in
which this plays out uh
you can consider that sort of like a uh
hypertrophic
exploitation of
um
supernormal stimuli right like what is a
supernormal stimuli like these stimuli
that we have that are essentially we've
discovered as part of this reflective
process of Discovery in the domain of
science we've discovered particular ways
of tapping into evolved
um evolve perception action Loops that
are unbounded in their sensitivity right
like there's no you know it's very hard
to identify upper upper Bound for uh you
know how the extent to which you can
advertise self-undermining uh uh food
products or you know ways of spending
your time if in the moment those produce
some sort of extremely positive or
extremely uh uh some high salience
positive affect uh uh experience like
eating sugar or
um you know getting that dopamine
release from the anticipate anticipation
of acknowledgment of one's perspective
online or you know these types of
economic threads that we have created
are specifically you know the profit
maximization threat I think this is this
is often put on the shoulders of the
word capitalism uh as a pointer to some
sort of hand wavy like there's something
going on here and it's capitalism
um but I think at a deeper level what
we're pointing to here is the fact fact
that
because of this very long lineage of
frames that we have chosen and and then
in many ways like adapted to live within
as a function of past adaptive
challenges we now live inside this
maximal representation of uh of those
ideas
in a way that is no longer sustainable
so like profit maximization has a myopic
Focus leading to identifying those
narrow set of Dimensions that are most
in line with that narrow metric over the
sort of corporate function and then
tapping in that that actually
successfully tapping into aspects of all
the aspects of human psychology and
perception that are unbounded it was a
search function and eventually it was
going to come to rest on like probing
The Human Experience in mind until it
found those parts that literally would
not uh you gotta go I gotta go guys
sorry
indeed Jordan
great talk thank you
in any case yeah that's another that's
another um that economic threat is
another thread to pull on but that was a
great conversation
in this uh in the active over time I
just want to run through a few hits yeah
that I uh wrote down from this great
convo and just plant some seeds for how
maybe we can continue 35.2 or in the
future
all right so in the very beginning
there was a discussion of something like
a meta Theory among the three of [__]
with respect to science heck with
respect to business and tainted with
respect to politics and
we can even see that meta Theory as the
prototypical
perception cognition action or eco-evo
Devo Loop so you spoke to the
transformational mapping between
perception and action which is basically
what cognition is we just say it's
everything between
that map between perception and action
and hence active inference as a
prototypical framework for not solving
but framing some of these contexts
then yeah there's a structured way of
mapping those first steps onto available
actions and then and identifying I mean
interestingly enough like one of the
most essential aspects of the framework
is that capacity to switch between the
development or like reduction of
variational free energy in the moment
understanding like whether my
representation of parsing reality in
action what I'm doing is actually in
line with uh the causal structure of my
local environment versus this explore
exploit future oriented frame of
reference in light of um when is it time
to actually uh search out some
disruption or some entropy so that that
entropy injection into my locally uh
ossified frame can open me up again to
uh navigating that adaptive landscape
and introducing new maps between
perception and action that can
facilitate my continued adaptation
awesome so I wanted to actually go to
the free energy with we had the earliest
Epoch of human collaboration
which Jordan characterized as sort of an
unconscious
and that is a lot like type 1 thinking
in the type 1 type 2 system and it's a
lot like variational free energy it's
just this real-time unfolding
ball goes downhill modality
type 2 thinking second stage
civilization as per Jordan and expected
free energy is where we actually have
the double-edged sword of the rollout
and anticipation and we've seen
simulations in octave where a tiny
proportion of hypothesized negative
outcomes even if they're totally
avoidable
Drive rumination and anxiety and high
variance estimates and then the question
is
is there a third Epoch is there a third
mode that uses attention to modulate the
balance or the Reliance between the
variational and the expected free energy
and to what extent is that attentional
modulation
implicit tacit on board not automatable
and to what extent could that kind of
wisdom be reflected in our externalized
niche
and that connects to the question of
Automation and transparency around our
information architecture Communications
and our infrastructure
and
I I thought of first a sort of
infrastructural incompleteness or
instability theorem like even if you get
all of layer one automated then of
course Layer Two has not been automated
so there's always the hyper prior
and um also that Min to opponent
processing thinking with tensegrity
architecture compression and tension
could we have systems where instead of
just trying to oh we want this object
hanging here we'll just put a pillar
underneath it and then we'll put a pill
underneath that like are we going to
compress all the way down or could we
have a harmonic mode that involved
compression and tension and that's how
it stayed flying
then just yeah last oh go ahead and then
I have two last points
I I'd go either way but yeah I mean
there's there's a lot of resonance here
with some of the things I'm working on
literally right now in terms of uh
attempting to uh attempting to
work with active inference as a like I
was saying earlier as a uh that
cognitive mapping like that that mapping
you can look at it also as a category
theoretic mapping
um within a category and a set of
morphisms right between this sort of uh
space of perception and the space of
action and you can then also
in that sense integrate that into a
larger
hypothesis around the topology of
emergence and then develop that as a
toolkit which is interesting because
inactive inference through the lens of
active inference in theory everything
can be active inference and then it
leads to this sort of recursive
hierarchical structure but
following thinkers such as like Robert
Rosen in terms of his and like uh
vashevsky and relational biology and
bringing in theories of a temporal
causal structure
that basically can contextualize the
temporal unfolding of entailments you
can actually use those understandings to
you to to take active inference as a as
a tool and weave it into larger Fabrics
like you're talking about and and those
fabric connections they are related to
active inference but they're not
necessarily
active inference itself although you
could then take a meta step outside of
that and say we can apply the principles
to the entire system but but there's
this role of understanding novel
closures of observing of reflexivity and
that reflexivity I think is a really
like the person I describe is the
approach I'm taking to introduce a a
different kind of reflexivity and a kind
that I believe is consonant with
multi-scale arbitrarily complex
emergence into the to the world of
active inference but you know
experimenting with how to stitch active
inference together into itself I think
is a very uh you know the entire field
is new and exploratory but even amongst
that it's a is that the sort of
periphery in the edge of exploration
um so
indeed and just these last two points uh
Brie collage was mentioned and active
inference helps us with the
composability legibility and simulation
emulation analytics on different systems
physical cyber physical cognitive
unknown
Etc so if we're doing brick collage on
the edges now we have the glue or the
sticky tape or whatever it is and then
last point was on the peacocks and
pyramids
it's not so simple as just an Adaptive
buffer even throwing a pleiotropy so the
consequences on different phenotypes uh
aside because it becomes integrated as
the kind of thing I am
and so yes it's like the Eraser is the
capacity of the pencil but we don't rub
our erasers all the way down we're not
always on our last life in the video
game and a symbol that on one hand the
energy could have been diverted to some
other purpose that symbol can actually
become
um
an introduction at even the mythopoetic
level
and therefore actually
lose its capacity to be an Adaptive
buffer at one level
and become a pivotal player
at another level the buffer I think that
is that's also like related to that
Instagram problem right where it's like
and it's particularly with respect to
the abstraction of that buffer as well
right so like if you abstract the buffer
as wealth the buffer is inferior signal
of underlying quality of behavior to
accumulating
resources uh over and above the
requisite level of short-term
consumption or metabolic need right
that's the evolutionary Instinct we have
for sort of appreciating someone who has
quote unquote gathered well at least by
means that were constructive or
generative
um but then you can you know to the
extent that becomes associated with
identity right and then you look at the
signals as that wealth manifests in a
particular culture as the proxy
measurement for the underlying for the
underlying phenomenon then you can start
to get into the manipulation of those
signals if someone understands and
observes others behaving as if the
signals were the process of production
of that capacity for well that the
capacity production of generating wealth
or useful byproducts then you can see
again this immersion parasitism uh
element dropping in there because people
will try to middleman that process and
say if if I can get you to treat me as
if I am that person maybe I can get
access to whatever Associated uh
privileges come alongside that so so
yeah 100 that's a um
that identity Association and and all of
the games that it opens up are is
essentially Central what's your main to
what we're talking about what we were
talking about
awesome and uh a closing thought
the discussion made me think of a July
4th fireworks for information what does
it look like when the
Weaponry is turned into livingry and
when there can be a symbolic ritual
around the utilization of
that dual functional technology
within the boundaries
across those levels
yeah I mean we're in a beautiful time
for that right now I think so much of
the emerging technology the generative
Technologies out there especially under
the auspices of AI or ml
um
the capacity to use that generative
toolkit and it's its ability to allow
people to uh a much broader swath of
people to produce potentially resonant
artistic and cultural artifacts that are
Pointers to something they find unique
or interesting or insightful that might
then spread if it aligns with a given
moment or need and that's particularly
fascinating to me as a
as a catalyst for increasing our
capacity to think collectively uh you
know transcending just the verbal domain
and bringing in other sensory modalities
uh aligned with the word I mean that's
the funny thing about these llms right
like they're large language models and
you know language can act as that fabric
as that as that
um
you know language as the net neural
network itself as the as the
computational network between these
other sensory apparatus and and the
ability to to produce artifacts that
bring people into forms of alignment or
phenomenological resonance that just
would not have otherwise existed
um now you know people are there are
potential downsides this as well just
like anything but you know I'm very
excited about that because I look at you
know the all of the art that I've seen
uh this new generative artwork it is
like you know very much informational
fireworks right people are able to take
five ideas they heard today you could go
you know based on this podcast you could
basically say like take any subsection
of that produce a series of generative
artworks and then associate that lineage
or like that like series of generative
art with this as a network a visual
Network that could be a dynamic
placeholder you know that could attract
attention uh automatically from the
potential Network that resonates with
that artwork right and and and tap into
the latent space of this conversation
that none of us hold explicitly in our
heads but we're all pointing to it based
on our words and our conversations and
the kind of things we're trying to talk
about here like there is a latent space
representation uh possible so yeah I
mean I think we're in fascinating times
for that and using that as a tool
constructively and wisely and I'm
looking forward to seeing seeing that
part of this unfold
thank you Matthew thank you to Jordan
till next time
yeah I think so always a pleasure